tout le monde sans la communication et
le partage avec autrui merci de
l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes-vous déjà demandé à quoi
ressemblerait notre monde sans le
partage sans la communication sans les
rencontres sans la transmission
je me présente je m'appelle Rémi Camus
je suis aventurier explorateur et
formateur technique de survie
alors si on regarde un petit peu sur la
survie et bien il existe une règle qu'on
appelle la règle de trois c'est une
règle qui permet de hiérarchiser votre
priori de vos priorités dans un
environnement de survie ou alors
d'extrémergence ça peut varier en
fonction de votre âge de votre condition
physique du biotope dans lequel vous
êtes en train d'évoluer et puis de vos
connaissances
c'est une règle qui est très connue du
milieu militaire et puis de toutes les
personnes qui aiment faire des
randonnées des trek vous avez déjà
entendu parler de cette règle de trois
ça vous dit quelque chose
alors je vais vous les énumérer comme ça
vous allez l'avoir en tête
on commence avec cette règle sur trois
secondes d'inattention
alors 3 secondes d'inattention c'est la
chose bête vous êtes en train de marcher
en pleine montagne vous avez un point de
vue culminant magnifique et puis juste
devant vous il y a un trou vous faites
pas attention vous mettez le pied dedans
et on se fait une cheville
mais ça peut être également dans la vie
de tous les jours vous êtes au volant de
votre voiture le téléphone est posé sur
le siège passager ça sonne vous pencher
pour regarder qui est en train d'appeler
et la voiture juste en face de vous qui
laisse à ce moment là
ensuite on parle de trois minutes sans
oxygène dans les organes vitaux
alors c'est un truc qui peut arriver
dans tous les jours si vous partez par
exemple à la piscine vous êtes en train
de nager il y a plein de gamins il y en
a un qui vous saute dessus et il trouve
que vous êtes une bouée plutôt
confortable
qui s'appuie sur vous vous êtes sous
l'eau et lui là dessus trois minutes
c'est des moyennes à peu près
ensuite on va parler de trois heures
trois heures sur la régulation thermique
notre corps doit maintenir sa
température à environ 37,2 donc il faut
toujours faire attention à l'hypothermie
et l'hyperthermie
ensuite on va parler de trois jours
d'après vous trois jours de quoi
exactement trois jours sans boire sans
boire de l'eau
mais qui peut faire autre chose trois
jours sans boire de l'eau on a besoin
d'hydrater notre corps régulièrement
ensuite d'après vous trois semaines sans
quoi
exactement trois semaines sans manger
donc on a des réserves trois semaines
sans manger on a le temps puis on passe
à trois mois qu'est-ce qu'il y a en
trois mois
et 3 mois d'hygiène vous allez vous dire
je comprends pas alors c'est pas ce
brosser les dents pendant c'est pas ça
j'en connais certains qui se lavent pas
pendant un an et tout va très bien pour
eux mais c'est pas là-dessus c'est plus
si par exemple vous partez dans une
forêt dans un environnement très hostile
vous allez vous ouvrir le bras vous
allez vous faire mal aux pieds et bien
ça va s'infecter peut-être ça va
gangrener il faudra prendre une décision
dans cette règle de trois dans tous les
cas la finalité c'est souvent la mort
et enfin on va parler de trois années
sans d'après vous
exactement contact social
quand on regarde cette règle dans son
ensemble et bien le début de cette règle
est très axé sur la partie physiologique
du corps humain l'air prêt vous avez la
régulation thermique l'eau la nourriture
mais plus on avance sur les mois voire
les années on passe sur autre chose
quelque chose de qui est indirecte à
l'aspect physiologique du corps humain
c'est les rencontres c'est le partage
c'est la communication
si l'être humain est coupé de
communication si vous avez plus de
contact social si vous êtes perdu sur
une île déserte pendant quatre ans et
que vous trouvez un ballon qui s'appelle
Wilson et que vous commencez à lui
parler
ça va très mal et donc forcément on a
besoin de ces relations parce que sans
ça et bien il n'y a aucun sens à la vie
les interactions sociales sont la base
de la survie et de notre bien-être en
tant qu'être humain
j'ai eu la chance de réaliser de grandes
aventures depuis longtemps et même si
mes aventures étaient très axées sur le
dépassement de soi
c'était quelque chose qui était ancré en
moi et que je voulais vivre à travers
mes aventures et bien même si lorsque je
parte à l'autre bout du monde la notion
d'être seul et quelque chose qui
m'intéresse également ce que j'aimais
vivre à travers mes aventures et bien
c'était les aventures humaines qu'il y
avait et ça c'était excitant
alors je vais vous partager quelques
anecdotes pour vous puissiez comprendre
un petit peu ce que je veux dire sur la
notion du partage des rencontres et de
la communication
2011 je décide de faire ma première
aventure de traverser le continent
australien en courant Melbourne Darwin
ce qui fait à peu près 5400 km en
courant avec une petite remorque qui
fait une quarantaine de kilos construite
par mon papa
5400 km en 100 jours et donc le but
c'est d'aller rencontrer les aborigènes
dans deux communautés la première
s'appelle kaltoukajara je vous
demanderai après et la deuxième elle
s'appelle muttijulu et il parle un seul
langage qui s'appelle le pitchengerra
prenez des notes attention
donc on est en janvier 2012 je suis à
yulaara qui se trouve en plein centre de
l'Australie pas très loin de Alice
Springs la grande ville et donc on est à
proximité du parc où le localacuza et je
désire aller donc dans la première
commute aborigène qui s'appelle
ils prennent pas de notes quel
tocadjarra
et donc je suis avec ma petite remorque
je regarde la distance il y a environ
270 km pour pouvoir arriver dans la
communauté de aborigènes donc je fais la
première portion qui est relativement
simple c'est de la route du bitume et
j'arrive à kalashotta donc c'est 36
dômes qui sont dans le parc magnifique
et je me trouve à cet endroit là et je
sais que la portion qu'il va y avoir
entre kalashuta et la communauté se
situe environ à 200 km c'est une piste
de terre battue avec du sable rouge qui
s'enfonce plutôt bien avec une remorque
chargée à 40 kg j'ai plein d'eau plein
de nourriture je suis paré et j'estime 4
jours pour faire les 200 km je commence
à avancer tant bien que mal il y a pas
grand monde on est dans le bouche
australien il y a pas de voiture il y a
très peu de véhicules très peu de
camions les seuls véhicules qui passent
c'est les aborigènes personne s'arrête
forcément et puis au loin on voit de la
fumée
et forcément s'il y a de la fumée c'est
qu'il y a une activité il y a un
véhicule qui arrive c'est un gros camion
le camion s'arrête à ma hauteur
et moi je suis en train de regarder la
peine du camion il y a une cuve remplie
de carburant et devant il y a une cuve
qui a rempli de flotte et je peux vous
dire que je suis en train de baver
devant la cuve qui remplit d'eau en
train de me dire j'aimerais bien pouvoir
l'avoir aussi celle là le monsieur
descend et c'est ce monsieur là
sur cette image là
je suis avec lui en plein milieu de
l'Australie il sort du véhicule et il me
dit bon écoute je prends cette route là
très régulièrement
j'ai vu des mecs en vélo j'ai vu des
mecs en moto j'ai vu des mecs en 4x4 en
voiture c'est la première fois que
j'envoie en train de courir est-ce que
tout va bien je dirais il fait un petit
peu chaud faut imaginer c'est lunaire il
fait 52 degrés
il me dit tout va bien il fait chaud je
suis juste avec mon eau et ma nourriture
mais ça devrait le faire dis ok très
bien fait demi-tour il remonte dans son
véhicule et il me sort et bien ce qu'il
y a dessus un sandwich avec du jambon et
des des
cooking je n'ai plus en anglais ramène
cornichon merci avec des cornichons et
ma sœur des céréales des barres de
céréales il me donne un coca light et un
café glacé qui venait de sortir de son
réfrigérateur à l'intérieur de son
véhicule un café glacé il fait 50 degrés
ça a été mon plus beau cadeau de Noël de
me retrouver en plein milieu du bouche
australien avec un mec qui s'arrête et
qui vient juste partager quelque chose
avec un total inconnu parce qu'il c'est
juste me faire plaisir et je lui dis
mais toi tu vas faire comment ne
t'inquiète pas pour moi j'ai encore 300
km j'attendrai bien pour avoir un point
d'eau et un peu de nourriture
je peux vous assurer que je me suis
arrêté et j'ai dégusté ces barres de
céréales et ce coca light avec ce café
glacé en plein posé vraiment dans le
bouche à me dire mais j'ai une chance
inouïe d'avoir vraiment vécu ce meilleur
cadeau de Noël j'aurais pu avoir
en 2018 pardon en 2013
je décide de faire la descendre du
fleuve Mékong en hydrospeed donc du
Tibet jusqu'au Vietnam ça représente
4400 km avec un flotteur qui me permet
de descendre tout le fleuve entièrement
le but c'est d'aller rencontrer des gens
et essayer de comprendre leur mode de
vie autour de l'eau
et puis j'ai une problématique sur mon
visa mon visage chinois va bientôt
s'expirer il va falloir renouveler ce
visa donc là j'essaye de trouver la
solution et je me mets de à faire
l'aventure dans l'aventure je trouve un
petit village perdu sur un bassin de
rétention d'eau je laisse toutes mes
affaires au médecin du village et je lui
dis garde ça il faut que je passe c'est
vraiment un plan bizarre complètement
pourri je la mets je lui dis je vais
partir en Birmanie pour sortir du pays
et revalider mon deuxième visa et
Morgane je prends mes affaires mon petit
sac à dos et je pars l'aventure dans
l'aventure j'arrive dans une toute
petite ville je dis petite à ce que
là-bas c'est vraiment petit de plusieurs
millions d'habitants et je me retrouve
avec un monsieur qui travaille au PSB
pour les sécurité border et ce monsieur
je lui explique que ce que j'essaie de
faire et que je voudrais passer en
Birmanie je me dis mais attends il y a
une petite problématique si tu passes en
Birmanie tu n'as pas de visa birman je
suis non pas du tout d'accord donc là tu
vas passer tu vas sortir de la Chine et
tu vas te retrouver dans un no man's
land et la Chine va pas t'accepter parce
que tu n'es pas sorti j'avais
effectivement ça va être problématique
donc il est génial une idée pour
quelques poignées de dizaines d'euros je
vais annuler ton visa et je t'en referai
donc je me retrouve avec un nouveau visa
super content de 30 jours bien plus ce
qui n'en fallait pour pouvoir sortir de
la chimie je fais tout le chemin inverse
pour retourner et bien dans ce petit
village et je me dis ça sert à rien de
de partir autant en profiter je suis là
autant passer un petit peu de temps avec
les gens et donc je retourne voir ce
médecin du village pour discuter avec
lui il me dit tu vas d'aller dormir déjà
dans un petit hôtel à proximité et puis
tu pourras venir tous les matins tous
les milliers le soir manger avec nous il
a une toute petite maison doit faire 9
mètres carrés la chambre se trouve à
l'arrière et il a une toute petite pièce
de vie où il cuisine et c'est également
l'endroit où il mange il a sa grand-mère
sa femme sa fille et lui-même on est
posé tous les matins tous les midis et
tous les soirs
à côté de moi il y a sa femme et en face
il y a sa grand-mère avec sa grande
fille qui est juste à côté et elle est
assise vraiment assez loin de moi ça
c'est le premier jour elle me regarde en
passant la tête sous les bras de sa
grand-mère
le deuxième jour elle s'est déplacée
elle entre la grand-mère et moi puis
elle me regarde se demande c'est qui ce
grand barbu là qui est habillé
bizarrement comparé aux autres le
troisième jour elle est assise à côté de
moi avec des yeux comme ça en train de
me regarder en train de essayer de
comprendre qu'est-ce que je fais là
le quatrième jour je dois l'emmener à
l'école
j'ai la main dans sa main et on marche
ensemble on traverse tout le village
pour aller à pour aller à l'école et à
l'école je ne vois pas quitter les lieux
je dois rester avec elle et passer toute
la journée à apprendre les mathématiques
je comprends rien mais c'est pas grave
c'est des moments qui sont priceless
mais vraiment
le cinquième jour 6e jour on finit notre
séjour à ce moment-là et je leur fais
comprendre qu'à un moment donné
malheureusement il va falloir que je
reparte faire mon aventure donc je me
dirige vers le bord du Mékong je suis
habillé prêt à sauter dans l'eau et tout
le village est là tout le village elle
est en train d'attendre
que cette petite fille qui est au milieu
et tout village apparaît de me dire au
revoir et je regarde autour de moi et je
vois pas cette petite fille mais je vois
la maman alors je lui demande avec des
gestes parce qu'on parlait ni anglais
moi je parlais pas chinois alors je lui
fais comme ça avec les yeux et elle me
dit ça va pas du tout elle est en train
de pleurer il faut elle veut pas venir
donc je dis je vais partirai pas tant
que bien je l'aurais pas vu donc cette
petite fille et bien elle est partie la
chercher et quand elle est revenue elle
arrivait près de moi et on s'est mis
tous les deux moi je me suis mis à
genoux pour être à sa hauteur et on
s'est pris dans les bras j'ai versé des
larmes j'ai pleuré et elle aussi
on se comprenait pas communiquer juste
par des gestes par des sourires mais je
peux vous assurer qu'on avait une vraie
complicité et qui avait un vrai échange
entre nous et je suis reparti je lui ai
fait un gros bisou en lui disant je sais
pas si on se reverra un jour mais tu es
une chouette nénette et j'espère que tu
as réussi à plus tard dans la vie
et j'ai poursuivi mon aventure pour
terminer six mois plus tard et bien au
Vietnam
en 2018
j'ai fait un tour de France à la nage je
suis parti de Dunkerque et j'ai longer
les côtes françaises alors vous allez me
dire il a fait le tour de France les
Pyrénées je sais on nage pas bien dans
les Pyrénées
j'ai vraiment lancé les côtes françaises
ok donc j'ai fait 2650 km à la nage
pendant trois mois et demi je faisais
des étapes d'environ 25 30 km par jour
11 12 13 heures de nage à nager ce que
je retiens dans cette aventure humaine
et bien ce sont les centaines et
centaines de bénévoles qui étaient là au
quotidien pour me mettre des coups de
pied au cul tous les jours Rémi retourne
dans l'eau Rémi réveille-toi Rémi mange
faut que tu ailles nager encore encore
il te reste encore 1000 km vas-y tu vas
le faire
et on arrive à Monaco après trois mois
et demi d'effort et quand je suis sorti
de l'eau il y avait la banderole
je me suis dit nous avons fait un tour
de France à la nage sans vous on
n'aurait jamais réussi à le faire parce
que si vous n'avez pas été là pour me
pousser au quotidien c'était impossible
ce que je retiens de ce Tour de France à
la nage et bien c'est une autre notion
cachée derrière un poteau il y avait un
monsieur qui était là que personne ne
savait qu'elle allait venir c'était mon
vieux mon père qui est normalement ne
quitte jamais son village quand il a pu
clocher de l'église en vue il est perdu
mais il a fait l'effort de descendre
jusqu'à Monaco c'est un vieux bouc
il est arrivé près de moi personne ne
s'attendait à ça on s'est regardé je me
suis mis à pleurer et mon papa aussi on
a pleuré tous les deux on s'est pris
dans les bras et je lui ai dit il
a fallu trois aventures pour que tu
comprennes tout ce que je faisais
il m'a regardé et à sa manière il m'a
dit je t'emmerde
ça voulait dire je t'aime à sa façon
c'était une façon de communiquer parce
qu'il savait pas le faire
mon papa est mort l'année dernière et
j'ai mis 37 ans pour comprendre sa forme
de communication il savait pas parler
mais le simple fait d'être à côté de lui
et de poser ma main sur son épaule
pendant qu'il fumait une cigarette et
bien c'était suffisant pour lui pour
avoir de la présence et communiquer
la communication le partage les
rencontres et bien c'est des choses
essentielles pour l'expérience humaine
et l'aventure de la vie
on a besoin de ces échanges pour pouvoir
grandir pour pouvoir nous épanouir ils
sont indispensables
le partage quant à lui et bien permet de
créer des liens de tisser des liens
j'ai oublié de vous montrer ça ça
c'était mon papa
quand on a fait le tour de France à la
nage
et ces liens ils sont extrêmement forts
et quand vous partagez avec les gens et
bien vos émotions vos expériences quand
vous partagez vos doutes et bien vous
créer des choses beaucoup plus profondes
avec les gens qui vous entourent et
c'est extrêmement important et le
partage il a plein de formes moi je vous
ai parlé de ce que j'ai vécu sur
l'Australie pendant le Mékong ou sur le
Tour de France à la nage
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus beau que
par exemple partager du temps avec des
gens que l'on aime c'est extrêmement
important de partager du temps c'est une
chose inestimable le temps
toutes ces valeurs toutes ces notions
sont essentielles pour notre bien-être
pour notre croissance pour notre
développement personnel pour notre
humanité
au tout début je vous ai parlé de
transmission
et bien je peux vous dire que
depuis que je suis jeune papa d'une
petite fille qui a 8 mois et bien le mot
transmission il prend son sens pour moi
il va au-delà du simple partage parce
que je veux tout je veux pouvoir lui
enseigner un maximum de choses
alors si vous voulez pas voir notre
monde s'effacer tout doucement et bien
continuons à rencontrer à partager à
échanger afin de transmettre et bien de
belles valeurs aux personnes qui nous
entourent
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]